- Il vit aux Appartements
Mais début février, Alex a
appris qu'il était évincé
de son appartement, le 15 mars.
ALEX O'HARA, résident,
Appartements Lachapellee ça,
dans six semaines, c'est...
Normalement, dans ans
un pays normal, vous penseriez
que ce serait illégal de juste
donner six semaine, comme Al, c,
vivent avec un problème de santé
mentale et qui sont encadrées
par un organisme communautaire.
problème mental dans la santé
mentale... Et... alors c'était
un édifice qui est comme
supervisé avec l'assistance
- Mais laire ne veut
pas prolonger l'entente avec le
terme. Le bâtiment est à vendre
et le prix sera très élevé.
LOUIS-PHILIPPE MYRE
directeur général, Interloge
actuellement. On a une très
faible offre et =))9
qui est très, très, très forte.
- Pour les organismes qui
abordable de certains édifices,
la mi9.=O)oQ quasle.
- Parce qu'ils n'ont pas la
possibilité de faire des dépôtst
agressives dans le marché.
Donc, non, actuellement,
c'est des conditions qui sont
très défavorables au logement
- Même problème pour la
construction neuve dont
les coûts explosent.it des projs
il y a trois ans à 200 $ l
carré puis actuellement, on
parle de 350 $ le pied carréou r
des logements abordables exi
une intervention de l'État.
- Avec différentes mesuresntes s
de prêt, des ass
hypothécaires à faible coût, ou
encore des prêtsd'intéd'intéd'is
contributions non-les.
on rencontre un autre résident s
la chapelle.
depuis six ans. Déménager sera,.
Au moins, il a une alternative
hébergement en santé mentale
rest compliquée. On compte 3000
places d'hébergement en santérél
et 604 personnes en attente.
La pénurie touche d'autres
régions comme l'Outaouais, Laval
Et frappe des gens vulnérables
comme Jonathan.
"Je n'ai jamais vraiment vécucas
de plusieurs des 35 résidents.
- Je ne suis pas certain que
les gens vont être capablese en.
- L'établissement de santé
affirme avoir finalement réussi
à relocaliser les résidents
avant leur expulsion le 15 mars.
immobilier québécois qui est en
ébullition laisse de moins
en moins de place aux gens
Ici Davide Gentile,
Radio-Canada, Mont